now we've sorted that that was just sort
of reminder from yesterday we want to
apply this to be able to find out the
equations of tangents and normals to log
curves so rule this off and then
underneath that I'm gonna do it ever hit
ok let's consider this guy over here now
what I want us to do is to find the
equation of a particular tangent to this
curve I want to find the tangent or find
the equation of the tangent find the
equation of the tangent where and I'm
gonna select an x value for this
particular case I'm gonna go with x
equals 3 okay now to find the equation
notation change its a straight line
right we need two pieces we need two
pieces we need a point and we need a
gradient right that will give me point
gradient form and then off I go okay now
at the moment we don't know either of
those I said I'm a point I don't regret
it
I do have half a point though right I'll
points in X into y I've got next how do
I get the why I'll substitute this x
value into into this X up here and then
I'll get Y though let's just quickly do
that now it's really simple
no calculus required and we'll get a
number out of this okay so let's go when
x equals 3 y equals I heard it log log
six it's okay okay
two times three equals six cool brain
still functioning that's always a plus
okay now they're showing you a question
yeah please
ah okay so so we are going to need the
gradient here in a second
yeah in order to take these two pieces
of inflation and then get a tension out
we will need the gradient so at some
point we need the gradient function we
do need to differentiate it's what we're
about to do but it sort of doesn't
matter which one you do first yeah you
need the gradient you need the Y value
get him in whichever order you like okay
but that said let's take a shine
suggestion I need a gradient function
here to answer this so that's a
derivative right dy on DX okay help me
out this is one of these right you've
got an F dash in there sorry you've got
an F in there which means we've got an F
- so what's my derivative go there we
will get that key pad abacus there I
want to see this what I see this what's
F in this case 2x what's F - 2 and that
does indeed simplify to 1 over X now I
wonder by the way just a little sort of
interesting exercise how many of you got
to this in the homework and noticed
isn't that suspicious that's weird right
comes up all the time in fact if I gave
you log 3x or log 4x or Lord five
billion X they all they all have the
same gradient think before we actually
answer the question why would that be
does anyone have an answer yet why why
do that this is it's a different
function how could it be that has the
same gradient does anyone how many Ln E
is weird
Ln a sweet but doesn't always give you
the same gradient I what do you think
or five billion on five billion eggs
okay this is true but I mean I've got
this over this and that didn't become
just one over X right let me sort of
file that thought for now we'll come
back to that let's answer the question
remind me unless to why you think you've
got an answer what do you wanna just
keep going ah okay okay survives on to
something but before we lose track I
will return to device thought in about
three minutes once we get a derivative
out of this or a gradient out of this
and then get an answer so here's one
over X what do I do with that
I've got your derivative now what you
substitute X into the original function
you also need to substitute X into the
gradient function so when x equals three
our gradient is equal to just a straight
substitution wahlgren and now I can
actually put this together in point
green form right so I so therefore
tangent is what is point grainy form
someone help me remember going it's
right it's not start me off give me the
left arrow okay is that yep remembering
it stringing out okay XO so this
requires a next one a y1 and M our
gradient let's just pop it in right
there so at this point here yeah no no
no no don't don't apologize this is
really important why do we do this we
differentiated to give us the gradient
function the gradient function gives us
the gradient said okay yeah no don't
apologize the question helps us clarify
okay let's put everything in shall we
can we slop it all in what we got here
what was our arm Y value Y minus log of
6 and I have no idea what that is but
that's okay it's exact my calculator
I'll take care of that what did we say
the gradient was a third and then I've
got X minus three okay now this is the
actual tangent usually we like things to
look a little bit neater than this
so what I don't like fractions I'm kind
of discriminatory like that so I'm just
gonna multiply everything through what
number can I multiply everything
everybody get rid of that just three
right so that gives me 3y minus 3 log
six so far so good what I get on the
right I can just leave it it's okay well
when I multiply by three it just gets
rid of the affair so it's just X minus
three okay I'll do one more thing
general form is one of the ways to write
an equation of a straight line a nice
neat way so I'm gonna have all of my X's
let's see subtract X from both sides and
then I'm gonna add three if only three
super neat and tidy I'd multiply
everything through by negative one to
make that positive but I'm actually
pretty happy with that okay now you've
got desmos there hopefully from when we
did that previous question can you
please put in this into your your
graphing calculator get rid of
everything else so it's nice and clean
and then can I ask you to put in this as
well if we've got this right they should
actually mark in and intersection point
for us and with any luck it'll be this
in fact you can even double check that
in addition to putting in your log curve
and this straight line you can also just
type in 3 comma log 6 and it all plot
the point for you can you do that for me
first graph your actual graph our
straight line which we hope is a tangent
and our coordinates can someone call me
everyone you've got something I want to
see if we got it right for which
yep yep yep so that's because this is
not what I've got on the botton at the
bottom of the board look at it again
carefully
did it work now tit can you put in three
common log six for me as well just now
tit boom did we get it over to bracket 3
comma log six ln6
yeah yeah then I just go to late to late
yeah just in fact it should just do it
if you press in say yeah there we go
sorry not x66 doubt it did it work okay
number one it doesn't give me a point uh
your this is exactly what we're about to
say we're about children yes it's weird
right
yes I do
okay so Shh
are you satisfied we've got the tangent
can you me thumbs up if you got there
it's fantastic thank you much
okay last bit as promised I want to
return to device suggestion which was
about I lost it this so pens out of
hands for a second leads down I just
want to think about this last bit with
you and then I'm gonna set you loose on
exercise 3d leads down leads down I want
your full concentration okay so our
question was and this really will shift
out do we really understand how logs
work why is it that a different log
function somehow it gives me the same
derivative as this one over here well
let me ask you this right if I ask you
to differentiate x squared hopefully you
can tell me pretty reflexively that
that's 2x right what about the
derivative of say for example x squared
minus 5 what is that it's also 2x what
why is it that a different function can
they give you the same derivative why is
that yeah so this this symbol number the
single number at the end is irrelevant
because I've just I've just moved up and
down yeah so you're like where you are
doesn't matter it's about how steep you
are okay now look again at this this
doesn't look like it's making the same
change we're making over here but it is
I want you to go back to the first page
where we reviewed the log laws do you
remember that can you go back and find
it did it click did it click woops sorry
go back to that first page so it should
say something like a review of log laws
on the top yeah now with any luck it
might even be the very first log law
that we reviewed together right
it's about rewriting logs as multiple
logs or single logs how can they use the
log laws to write this in a different
way any takers
- love 10 2x over so you can talk about
changing the base I could change the
base but it just so happens that if I
change the base it doesn't look very
obvious about what's actually changed
okay there's another law you can use
there's another one that one works but
there's another one it's more helpful
what what do you think Alicia yeah yeah
sorta head up this is what we're looking
at here is this one of the laws there's
this one of the laws we wrote down it is
right when you see two logs same base
you add them together that means you
sort of multiply these bits in here
right but wait a second this what is
thisis this is just a number right that
just moves you up or down and this is
what we started with right so in fact no
matter what you change is 2 3 4 5 etc
all you're really doing in desmos will
prove this to you is moving the thing up
or down and that's why they have the
same derivative that makes sense